this is Mike and what year is this by
the way is this 2006 2005 uh maybe a
little before that okay so I'm sure what
that clip is so so watch how you're
defending Scientology this is Mike
rinder sitting on the board okay
International spokesperson you're gonna
hear a very different mic in this clip
than the one right here on the podcast
go for it played I've known Tom for uh
15 years I consider him a friend do you
think he's a good spokesperson for
Scientology I think he's a very good
representation of what a Scientologist
is I think he's uh obviously successful
he's uh obviously very happy
does a lot to help other people he lives
an ethical life but last year this door
was orbiting far from Planet Hollywood
into the galaxies of Scientology many
wondered did he wander off too far does
the church ever call Tom Cruise and say
you know what pull back the reins a
little no I don't think anybody in the
world calls Tom Cruise and tells him to
pull back the rant
but Tom Cruise and other celebrities do
promote scientology's agenda does the
church actively recruit celebrities no
no the church is open to anybody no one
specifically told we'd like to get more
celebrities because celebrities sort of
up the profile of Scientology we have a
list of celebrities
absolutely not absolutely not you can
puzzle right there how do you feel
watching this right now by the way
ridiculous I I mean is it time to watch
it or is it
I'm sort of used to it people have
shoved this stuff in my face for some
time have you seen this one I hadn't
seen that for a long time it's funny I
saw Hoda at an event that I did with
Leah one time for oh it was like the
premiere of the movie she did with JLo
and we were at the premiere and Hoda
walked in and she knows Leah pretty well
and she said oh hi no and I'm like
she said yeah I interviewed you I said
oh really okay now this I didn't recall
at that time that I had been interviewed
by her
and I say in the beginning of this book
one of the things that worried me about
writing it was the fact that sealed
members are so sleep deprived that you
have a sort of a you you live in a fog I
look at myself on that clip and I go oh
my God I look terrible I look like I
haven't slept for a month I look like
I'm sort of like sleep walking through
this interview dazed that is the
impression that I get of myself I'm
there and it's probably true
if that was 2006 I probably came out of
the hole to go and do that interview
like I did I was in the ho the whole
yeah what's every time every time can
you go back and see what he looked like
though
I actually thought you looked pretty
good there uh you you know it's
interesting that your take on that is
that you didn't feel like you looked
good oh you actually looked kind of pale
but yeah I look kind of pale much you
were saying the whole the whole is
it was
um something that was depicted on the
going clear HBO dock it was a prison uh
at the international headquarters of
Scientology in Riverside County uh
California and I I write a whole chapter
about the whole because it was where the
senior echelons of Scientology
hierarchy were locked up by David
muscavich and basically in a Lord of the
Flies World beating confessions out of
one another to in order to satisfy
miscavige that uh everybody had somehow
confessed to the terrible things that
they were thinking or doing that was
making his life difficult
um
I was a very unique
uh inmate of the whole in that when the
media would reach out for a spokesperson
to come and talk and they couldn't be
persuaded not to do the show at all I
would be taken out of the hole and
escorted to do an interview with the
media like someone would fly with me on
a plane to New York I talk about going
in on the Today show with Katie Couric
and lying about the the Xenu ot3 story
this with Hoda is another example of
that of being pulled out sent off and
answering questions in the way that it
was expected that would be uh the you
know the correct Scientology answer the
fact that I say in there that there was
never any effort to get celebrities in
Scientology is so absurd
there is an entire organization in
Scientology called the celebrity center
which is dedicated to attracting and
servicing celebrities because Hubbard
said very early on
celebrities are opinion leaders
they make people see things in a certain
way if Tom Cruise comes out and says I'm
a Scientologist and Tom Cruise is the
biggest movie star in the world then
there is a whole lot of people that will
go well if Tom Cruise is a Scientologist
may not be so bad maybe all this crap
I've heard about it isn't really true
maybe it really is helping him it might
it may be able to help me and Cruz was
recognized by David muscavich as being
the single source of the greatest number
of new scientologists in the history of
Scientology now whether that's true or
not is another thing there is also a lot
of [ __ ] that goes into these claims
that Scientology makes about anything
but
Tom Cruise was
perceived by David muscavich as the
biggest asset that Scientology had so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]